what's up my plebeians and peasants it's
don ladd aka the richest kid in america
that was great it was good that was
great fantastic good wow
that was uh that was quite the intro yes
that was how else could you introduce
the richest kid in america like
come on i just wanted to start this off
by saying i did a little bit of research
right before he came over
and i came across someone named preston
bezos
preston bezos that sounds like jeff
bezos right right
it just so happens to be and if my
calculations are correct
i believe he is probably the richest kid
in america
i mean if you say like that probably
that it's a possibility
but it's not because i'm the richest kid
in america and
what makes you the richest kid in
america is it verified
well it's not like verified it's not
like as a fact
but it's just who i am as a person it's
not like
money-wise it's just it's just me rich
in
in life experience and money and
how did that term come about we want to
know from the very beginning because
this all started
when i watched a video from a youtube
channel called truly with like 10
million subscribers
and they featured you as the richest kid
in america and it was like wait a second
i've seen you before
in other channels with faze rug yes
tanner fox i believe too
so you've been kind of floating around
the youtube scene
how did the richest kid start so it was
probably
three to four years ago i was walking my
dog bruiser of a french bulldog
around the neighborhood and i heard a
lambo so
i i walk over interest because i'm a big
car nerd
and it's faze rug and he's just chilling
in his front yard
i actually didn't even know who he was
so i was just talking for
him i was just talking to him for a
little bit and then
i went back home and i saw him on my
youtube recommended page i'm like
wait that's the guy i just met so a
little later i dm'd him and he responded
and he said he wanted to film so my
first video
actually was with face rug what was the
message what do you send to faze rug
to make him want to film i was i i
don't think i still have the message i
can look but it was something along the
lines like
hey you can come and film at my house if
you want to because he knows that i'm
his neighbor with the biggest house in
the neighborhood so
did you say that and then you must have
said that in a minute no he knew i
hadn't
when i met him i was talking he's like
where do you live i'm like the big one
up on the hill
wow okay so you're flexing on faze rug i
was i was
you went up and you one-upped him yeah
my house is like
up here and his is just like right down
the street so you look at his house yeah
do you wake up in the morning and just
look down at this house and be like
sometimes i'll be out in the backyard
and i'm like oh look
there's rug wow okay so he was he was
impressed
and uh he said he wanted to film what
did you guys film
so he came over and he did a house tour
he actually damned me he's like i want
to do like an mtv cribs type style video
so he comes over he films he surprises
me with tanner fox
and tanner also vlogs the like the day
exploring the house and then the next
day he's like are you ready for this
video it's going to be a banger
and i'm like yeah i can't wait to see it
and then i get the notification
meet the richest kid in america 13 years
old
wow that's a good that was a good time
that was a great that was a great
time
[Music]
i did a full reaction to his house tour
where he said it was a 10 million dollar
house i'm like the guy he paid three and
a half for it
i mean it's closer to being worth zero
than it is ten million dollars when you
put it that way
that is true so yeah i had no clue he
said he wanted to do a house tour and
then i just saw it on my phone
and then that video got over 10 million
views so
the name stuck with me then other people
started reaching out filming me like
jack dougherty the funk bros tanner and
they all used richest kid in america in
their title so it's like
what else would i call myself all these
millions of people
know me by the richest kid in america so
you just walked into it
it was kind of just like there and you
kind of just yeah i suppose that's
better than like calling yourself the
richest kid in america like at least
someone else gave you that title
and after 10 million views it kind of
sticks yeah it happened to me like the
name
was like not even given to me it wasn't
even an option like it was already out
by millions of people before i had a say
in it yeah
no not saying anything bad i don't mind
it i like the title but
i don't mind i like the title too now
i'm curious what did your parents think
when faze rug was going to go to your
house show it to millions of people
include you in the video and the title
was there any hesitation like maybe
he's 13 he should not be shown off our
house like this we want
we want to do the stealth wealth we
don't want people to know
well this was on my dad's house and my
dad's like very old-fashioned old style
he he has like three phones and he
doesn't use any of them because he
doesn't know how to work him like he
doesn't even know how to use his cell
phone
he he just he doesn't even know what
youtube is he calls me a podcaster
and i'm like that's how much he knows
about youtube according to him i'm a
podcast you have a radio show
exactly okay so he didn't he didn't know
what facebook was he had no clue when i
told him he has like 15 million
subscribers
that doesn't mean anything to my dad to
my dad it's just like hey i have a
friend coming over
that's a flex phase rug what is that i
step but we have that in the living room
we got a rug gee okay well i guess the
the question then is what does your dad
do
so my dad he's been retired for a little
bit but
he is into real estate mainly he owns
apartment complexes
he started off with like mobile home
parks but then he transitioned over to
apartment complexes he has many in
phoenix arizona where is he from
he is from los angeles wow
really how do you get into that i'm
curious well
at 25 or 26 his mom passed away
and she left him with a mobile home park
and then he took that business he worked
on it he kind of grew it up
and then his dad also helped him and
then he grew that he bought it
for 1.2 million he then just sold it
recently for 62 million
the same mobile home park the mobile
home park yes
so then he went from mobile home parks
with the 62 million he bought his
current house and then
just into other um apartment complexes
wow incredible so so he's retired so
he's not into
he still owns the apartment building
owns them all but he has managers
he has everyone working for him he just
sits at home and an occasional phone
call
is there is there a reason he's not in
the videos why not
why don't you guys he just
he doesn't really understand it so if i
ask him to be in it he'll say
sure it's about how old is he
he is 65. that's impressive
so ever how old are you right now i'm
15. and when the
video initially came out introducing the
richest kid in america how old were you
i just turned 13. so i've been at it for
two years so but what made you at 13
say that like okay now i want to run
with the richest kid title
you know this is where i messed up i
didn't
i had probably two posts on instagram i
didn't have a youtube channel i didn't
have a tick tock
so i think i grew 30 000 followers on
instagram
the first day but you know i just i
wanted to meet face rug i wanted him to
come film
i didn't realize at the time how big of
a youtuber he was
because i didn't even really watch
youtubers a lot of kids watch youtubers
like oh my gosh faze rug
when i met him i genuinely had no clue
who he was
and i didn't realize that he was so big
so i had him plug my instagram
but it had like two posts and i wasn't
consistent
i didn't post i had a youtube channel
that i created after that
that i made probably like one or two
videos a month
and i was growing like crazy but i
didn't understand the numbers i didn't
understand like
how successful it actually was and i
didn't push it enough
um got it but when did you start making
youtube videos then
and leaning into that probably a few
months after like two or three months
after
okay and then i had fun doing it and i
realized i wanted to do it
like seriously probably like six months
after
what do your parents think of that um my
mom she loves it she supports it she
helps me with everything
like she's always finding videographers
editors anything i need really
to help make my videos and then my dad
supports it he just
doesn't know a lot about it how much
money do you spend per video would you
say
because i've seen some we're doing some
pretty crazy stuff i saw you wrapped
your mom's car
yeah i spent um ten thousand dollars on
that
because they wrapped the entire car in
24 hours
they didn't help you out like they
didn't say like oh yeah we're getting
free promotion we'll wrap your car
i wish i i truly wish but no i i
actually paid for it
wow so that was we should probably also
introduce the fact that that was in the
video that graham initially reacted to
of you that was posted on you and then
you got back to graham and that's how
this whole thing came out right
what did you think of my reaction to you
i i loved it i thought it was good
you know i didn't no hard feelings from
it any complaints anything
anything i maybe missed in the video
anything maybe i said something that was
like that's not true
i think i think you were fair about it
okay but um
yeah you're like oh he calls himself the
richest kid in america but
as i've already explained you know
that's not really like my
calling to myself i don't mean to be
like cocky you know that was like
got it that's my title okay the house
you lived in
was also the house is is that the house
uh i won't say where did
los feel is yes yeah that's it you
actually live there we
actually bought that it used to be a
ponte house but yes we purchased it uh
so anyway i'm very familiar with that
house
oh yeah so we actually have a few issues
with the house like it's an awesome
house
yeah but like for example there there's
a leak in the ceiling
like they disclosed the house when they
sold it to us as there are zero
issues no issues with anything there's
quite a few
issues like there's a leak in the
ceiling and it was coming through the
speaker onto our couch
so we have a guy cut open the ceiling
see what's there and apparently the
house was leaking
and how they fixed the leak is they they
just put a bowl
under the leaf to catch the water
yes they put a bowl in the ceiling and
it just it just catches the water
but one day the bowl overfilled and it
started coming
no yes first i want to thank upstart for
sponsoring this video if you're carrying
a credit card balance month after month
it can feel like it's never ending i
mean debt is a huge
obstacle to overcome but upstart is here
to help you get on the path to financial
freedom by helping you pay off that debt
smarter and faster upstart is a super
fast and easy way to pay off all your
debt with a personal loan and the best
part is
is that it's all online you can pay off
credit cards consolidate any high
interest debt or even fund a personal
expense
over half a million people have used
upstart to get their loan with a simple
fixed monthly payment unlike your
traditional loan companies upstart
actually considers your income and
current employment to help you find a
smarter rate on your loan it only takes
five minutes to check your rate online
and you can see your percentage
upfront if you borrow between a thousand
and fifty thousand dollars and they work
so fast you get your funds as soon as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today by going to
upstart.com
ich that's upstart.com ich don't forget
to use our custom link to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined on your credit
income and other certain information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
ich thank you so much upstart for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
so you say you have didn't you say you
had multiple houses
how does how does this work well we
buy and sell and i've lived in probably
like 15 to 20 houses growing up
so right now we have two houses in san
diego
we have we just sold one or it's going
through
escrow in la and then we have the
current one we own la
and then a condo in la and then an
apartment in new york
and then we just recently sold our condo
in the bahamas but we're looking to get
another one
are these just empty in the meantime are
they rented out
uh one of them two of them are rented
out
one of them okay here's actually a funny
story
this is one of the dumb rich people
things my dad has done so he bought this
house
for like 6 million and
in rancho santa fe san diego great area
yeah great
right you know cielo uh-huh right up on
the top of the mountain
beautiful new modern house it was one
year old when he bought it
and so there were some olive trees he
wanted palm trees instead so he got
these
giant like 60 foot tall palm trees he
paid a million dollars for two palm
trees
how how is it a million dollars to do
palm trees
they're big palm trees like they're like
probably
that big or how tall really tall taller
than three-story house
it's like 40 feet 40 feet tall palm
trees how was it
and so they were craning them in okay
and they burst
pipes for the neighborhood by training
them in
yeah by the way or was it digging the
hole
and so the pies pipes burst it ended up
costing my dad two million dollars
and they're like digging through
replanting the trees all this
construction in his front yard
so what he did is he just left the house
15 minutes down the road
bought another house and for the past
three years
that one house has just been sitting
there empty well no one in it no
it's just sitting that doesn't make
sense to me so well first of all because
he found a bigger house he liked
the new house was 27 000 square feet
jeez well the last one was only 10
000. god okay so it has nothing to do
really with
the the pipe bursting if the pipe didn't
burst he wouldn't wouldn't have seen the
other house he liked
more exactly bought the new house it's
better
exactly why is there a reason he didn't
sell it or it's just like oh i guess
tech he's probably made a little money
keeping it empty
he i think he just forgot about it
genuinely
like i remember once like two years
after it happened i asked him about it
and he's like
i don't know like he does i was
thinking like what what if i just go up
there and like stay for a few nights
like it's a giant mansion in rancho
santa fe just
empty and what did he say oh no i didn't
ask him yeah
i haven't been there in a while but i
was can we stay there right we should
all go can we make a trip to rancho
santa fe i would do it stay in the
second house i would do it in a second
it's like giant water slide infinity
pool come on
over i would love to go if you said if
you send him a tax you say graham we got
this weekend at the house just one day
just one day just one has like a movie
one yes one day and but we have to spend
the night
okay one day yeah and then that way you
could say you were over there i would do
it
my bed's like bolted into the ceiling in
that house it's like a really cool house
the there's like i think 17 ipads that
control the house
and like you're in the movie theater you
like press a button all the lights will
go off all the ch
chairs will recline and like drapes will
open and it presents you like the movie
how much is the house worth uh i think
he bought it for six million
but that doesn't make sense to spend six
and then spend another
million on palm trees like how how why
would you why would that ever make sense
for
the six million dollar house has been a
million my dad is the person you need on
this podcast okay
you need to talk to my dad okay he's the
person that buys million dollar palm
trees
because he likes the look of them would
he
come on the podcast he probably would
he's he's
a fun person he has a lot of stories
okay
i would do i think one of his apartment
complexes first is for sale right now
for
155 million no really in phoenix yeah
one of his main how much was the new
house that he wanted to buy in san diego
though or that he did
that he did buy um it was built built
for
30 million and it took five years to
build
wow and he has like one painting worth a
million dollars
because it's like his whole ceiling when
you first walk in is like hand painted
so he that was a custom piece yes then
the whole ceiling was a custom piece
are you able to disclose his net worth
or what his like what you think it might
now i'm just kidding now we're just
curious
yeah because at first you were like yeah
you sold the thing for what 60 million
i'm like oh
it's probably what's right i thought it
didn't i started to stop there oh no
stop staring that was like i would be
like one of the smaller businesses
yes small businesses yeah he has the one
for sale for like 155 million
and that's one out of like six apartment
callbacks is he
partners on this or is it just like he's
a one-man show no it's him he has some
partners with other stuff
wow uh any time he works with partners
it doesn't go well
wow i believe it i mean listen at that
level you don't need partners
that's true yeah you are the partner why
kevin o'leary
yeah like him yeah that's incredible
that's i mean
do you do you know what probably like
like 300 million for him
just like you could guess if you don't
know you don't know it's fine genuinely
i have no clue what he does with his
money
i'll be in a hot tub with him and he's
like
i just invested a hundred or 200 000 in
this stock and this and he's like
oh i just made however many million
doing this i have no clue because
every day he does some random thing that
could cost him millions or
make him millions you ever curious
though because if if that were my
i'd be like all day be like let me see
what you do all day
and he just says a lot he doesn't tell
me exactly how much money he has
that i mean that could be for the best
because then it's like we
don't exactly know but i would be just
like just kind of following kind of
watch and see
what's going on he definitely makes a
good income
wow so yeah so were you born and then
you
grew up your entire life with this like
level of wealth or was this something
that happened more recently
oh no he's had this he's he's always
been wealthy for the past like 40 years
or his family they've always been
wealthy but just like in the past
probably
10 15 20 years has he gotten like really
wealthy
yeah eight figures or wait no nine
figures nine faces yeah yeah
why does he live in california uh he
just likes it
i we know that taxes all that stuff
obviously he hates that part
but he just loves the weather and
he he just loves looking at california
living in california
at that point it doesn't matter i don't
think right it's the principle of it
like i
you know we were trying to uh to find a
good deal on a sony
a7 s3 and i'm looking at the price
online it's like thirty six hundred
dollars thirty five hundred dollars and
i'm like no wait that's too much
i want to get the used one and save a
few hundred bucks and so it's just the
principle of it it's it's like
if you don't have to spend that much
maybe you spend a little bit less oh
agreed
so that that's the way i look at it but
his businesses are
all in arizona um
so i don't know how he does that all i
know is in like in 2018
he paid no income tax legally with right
yes
maybe that's maybe that's how he's
staying in california because here's the
thing if if
his businesses are in arizona if he's a
full-time resident of california it
doesn't matter where your income
if you live in california and that's
where you reside that's where you pay
tax
if if he's in arizona he would pay tax
on arizona
but yeah i'm sure he's able to use a lot
of those buildings just right off
everything
so yeah i mean hypothetically you could
have 100 million dollar net worth
make on paper 8 million a year but then
pay
no tax yeah it's possible
i don't know what he's doing but uh it's
possible i just want to know what it was
like to grow up with that level of
wealth
like like how was your you know day
different than others were your friends
the same like wealth status what was it
like
so right now i don't like to consider
myself like a spoiled brat
but i do admit when i was younger i
definitely was
so we would have like limos come pick us
up
like everywhere we go like to take us to
the airport and then like once we get
checked in at the airport always first
class
uh my dad never flew private he doesn't
like little planes
he doesn't even really like planes but
um i remember like i was just on a
first-class flight
this was like because usually we fly to
like europe
or like across the country you know
where you get like your own like little
room you lay down
i've seen those videos yeah yeah that
was like all i flew
until i was like eight and then i went
on a shorter flight it was like three
hours
and i'm in first class but it's just
like a normal first class sleep
a normal first-class seat and i was like
throwing a fit i'm like this first class
sucks you can't even lay down the tvs
are so small
i'm probably like six or eight years old
and i'm throwing a fit because of how
bad the first class was
wow that's incredible you know i've
never flown first class
ever yeah one day one day i will use
i'll use some credit card points on that
first i want to thank our sponsor
grammarly with all the different youtube
channels we run as a team it's important
to streamline our workflow and save as
much time as possible and one of the
best ways we've done that is with
grammarly premium we use grammarly
premium to give us real-time feedback on
our writing all throughout the day i
personally use grammarly premium when
i'm emailing other creators inviting
them onto the podcast
writing sponsor scripts just like this
one and don't tell graham but i
even use it sometimes when i message
people on tinder have you had any luck
with that no it hasn't helped with
tinder
yet but it's it's not grammarly's fault
grammarly premium has tons of different
features such as clarity suggestions to
help me get my message across
quickly without using repeated or
unnecessary words and they also give me
vocab suggestions to replace overused or
platitudinous words and phrases it's
super easy to see how i can deliver my
message clearly and accurately the first
time with grammarly premium and with
their browser plugin and mobile app i
can use it anywhere i go
hit send with confidence and get your
point across more effectively with
grammarly premium get twenty percent off
gramerly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
iced coffee that is twenty percent off
at g r a
m a r l y dot com slash iced coffee
thank you so much grammarly for
sponsoring this video and back to the
podcast
so other than that like what was it like
you know you had limos everywhere did
you have i'm sure you had private chefs
always like at your house
yeah we don't have chefs that live with
us but we've had like chefs
like come over and cook because my dad
owns a sushi restaurant
no way in san diego i want to go
in la jolla like by the beach wow that's
beautiful
yeah so they'll come and cook or he
likes to throw parties but with kova he
hasn't really thrown
many wow i remember he said like one
party he got like 50 000 worth of
alcohol
um like big parties that must be like
it's champagne like
it's got to be expensive champagne 50 50
a lot of hard liquor too yeah but that's
not like 50 grand where it's got to be
wise
yeah yeah it's really nice stuff yeah
and at what point in your life did you
realize
that you were like well off or like to
the extent that you were
we because the thing is we lived in
neighborhoods where every other person
and like you're going to country clubs
every person
is like very wealthy i'm probably at
like
12 years old or like 11 or 12
i was like going to like my other
friends at school houses
and then like whenever they came over to
our house they were like oh my gosh and
i was like
i just thought it was normal because
that's all i've ever seen was like
been in all these very luxury my mom
kept me in like a really
real bubble when i was young so i was
probably like 11 or 12 i realized that
we were even just wealthy
[Music]
and how would you say growing up with
that level of wealth has affected your
happiness do you think that you've been
a lot happier having it do you think it
doesn't affect your happiness do you
think it affects it negatively
or also do you think it sets sets the x
but it sets the bar too high
it definitely says the bar really high
like if you
because now my parents are divorced i
live with my mom but when we were
together my dad
obviously has more money than my mom
he's very
very well off so then like when you do
normal things or
like we can we never wait in lines for
anything
it's like i i know that sounds terrible
like now
we like wait in lines normal stuff but
like when we were younger there were no
lines for anything because
no one else was like doing what we were
doing really like
they when you go you take the um like
the limo to the airport and they check
in
at the like the lounge like the delta
one area uh
so there's like now when you like wait
in lines it's like
it sets the bar so high because when
everything you do is like the top of the
world the most
luxurious out of everything then when
you do things that are even just like
nice they're just like they don't
impress you as much
hmm but maybe this could be good
experiences to see like a bit of both
you know great experiences it doesn't
make you happier but
it gives you a lot it gives you a lot
more
options to do things that make you happy
yeah sure like
if you really enjoy like scuba diving
you can like go to australia and like
scuba dive with whale sharks or like
stuff like that
so it gives you the opportunity to do a
lot of things
did yeah i was just gonna ask have you
found it difficult to
to find something that you're passionate
about something that you could work
towards
if you don't necessarily need to in the
first place
i fell in love with youtube
uh like and just like the influencer
life
probably like a year and a half ago in
the beginning i wasn't too about it
but then when i started learning like
the algorithm and doing all the tags and
that stuff i got like
so natural at it and i learned so much
and i like i have fun
making content no matter like what it is
did you get an allowance as a kid no
i just i i've never heard my dad say no
like
oh like so that's tested that's credit
card numbers memorized so it's like
it's that so i'm just curious i know
this is such a dumb question but like
growing up as a kid i always wanted to
be able to like go to the local pizza
shop and just like pink i want a pizza
like eating and
buying food has always been like the
best thing ever for me would you be able
to
realistically spend your money on
anything whenever you want
as long as it's like under like a
hundred dollar value per day or
something like that
yeah yeah i mean that's it yeah yeah i i
also pay with a lot of stuff with my
money
because i have my card hooked up to my
phone so i just do apple pay everywhere
i go i pay for a lot of my stuff that i
like
want or but like obviously i have
like a house but like even when i'm out
i don't even really ask my mom like
hey i need money to do this because it's
easier for me to just pay with my own
money than for her to like send me money
got it well let's talk about your
finances for a second so
what are you what are you making between
every how is your business broken down
well it depends because you obviously
know
brand deals and sponsorships so like
right now i get paid to post instagram
reels you know what reels are
so for each reel i post i get 125
dollars
from who instagram how did how did that
how does that happen
that from my manager in brazil got me
that so i have a manager in brazil
and basically instagram is trying to
push the reels like tick tock
so they want all the like big users or
just like influencers to be posting
reels consistently
so then i have to post a minimum of
three a week but
for nine months instagram is paying me
to post reels
and i don't have to tag anyone hashtag
ad nothing just to post that's all i
have to do
that's good yeah that's really good okay
so be besides that then what about
just broad sponsorships ad revenue how's
it broken down
two or three days ago i filmed with
cinnamon toast crunch
they really yeah they brought
a really i don't know when this is
coming out but it's sure yeah they
brought a monster truck
and it like delivered cinnamon toast
crunch to me and like a big thing
i got paid like seven grand for that
where is that going to be is that for
cinnamon toast crunch or is that that's
for me
for your channel for tick-tock yeah they
pay me to post take talk
wow who is your manager how do we like
put the manager in test with jax his
name is fabio he lives in brazil
is he looking for more clients or
something like that because i text him
we fabio on this podcast we love
cinnamon toast crunch it is my favorite
breakfast
ever i i cannot survive without eating
cinnamon toast crunch
every day please sponsor us
i love cinnamon toast it's actually my
favorite series is it really growing up
that's like
all over it's been my favorite series
it's really good so then when they
reached out to me i was really happy
i'm actually being stupid now i'm being
serious
yeah it's been mine my favorite piece
are the ones at the very bottom
yeah and you bite into it it's not like
100 crunchy but it's kind of like
right a little soft because it's like
half the cinnamon
i have a crate at home not a box but i
have like a wooden crate
you open it up and it's just like boxes
of cinnamon toast crumbs i have like a
a lifetime supply of cinnamon toast
crunch you know what i'm surprised they
haven't done you know how oreos are the
double stuff oreo what about a double
cinnamon toast crunch
just double the cinnamon like if
everything if every piece i feel like
that would go against some sort of like
health standard
or something that would be pretty i mean
but it would be very good oh man yeah
but anyway okay so so cinnamon toast
crunch like give us some other example
i like this part um i've worked with
amazon nickelodeon
oh my just to like post a picture this
was back when i even had like 60 000
followers they paid me to post a picture
to like
create awareness for their tv show and
stuff like that
my sister helps me get brand deals my
brand manager
so it's just like all different and then
i always get free stuff
all over like this shirt is a
sponsorship they who
yeah what is that shirt party p-a-r-i
okay
they just sent me a ton of clothing most
of these
a lot of this originated would you say
from face rug from that one video of
course yeah the majority
even though they don't all subscribe to
me but that's also because i didn't even
have a youtube channel this was my
mistake
when i filmed with rug and that video
did huge so i'll be out
in public and i will get swarmed so many
people know who i am
i i have like 600 000 subscribers but
yet
millions and millions of people have
seen me like rugs one video has 11
million his other video has 10 million
tanner's video has
eight million funk first video has seven
million piper's video has seven million
so it's like so many different people
all over have seen me
and they like know who i am so i get a
lot of fans i get a lot of
like that also helps with brand deals is
like you as a person they don't really
care about your numbers so much
but like who you are makes me wonder
what phase
rug is getting i mean if these deals are
coming up for you
phase rock it it has to be a hundred
times
more i i i bet for faze rug to do that
same
thing the same uh uh commercial cinnamon
toast crunch
700 grand 500 no yeah yeah
i think so now what about your own like
uh philosophies for personal finance
investing
how much are you saving from what you
make
i don't really spend any of my money
except i do a lot of write-offs because
i'm like filming
like my camera my laptop because i use
that obviously to produce the content
and then when i'm like out filming if i
get like a snack i can write that off
because it's
what helped me like the filming and
stuff but like i never really
buy like things items like stuff i like
for myself so almost all the money goes
into a savings account but i do
invest in things like i actually
invested in this one
company is were they
thc and cbd you know how it's grown
so this company managed to create it in
a
lab and it is identical they're the
first people to
ever make lab-grown thc that
it's consumable and it is all the
everything is identical so i invested in
that
i got a thousand shares and now it
hasn't even came out yet and it's
already four
times its price okay but it's predicted
to go to like 20 times so i invested in
that
i have cryptos stuff like that
what about do you have a credit card no
i do not
can can you get a credit card i should
you should yeah i know that
build some credits authorized users
start building your credit score
that's what i would do yeah
immediately so that that's starting
monday gonna become an authorized user i
would do american express
american experience yes i think whatever
american express you have
yeah authorized the highest one the
centurion
really do you have it here show it can
we see it
oh my god oh my god you dropped it no
that shocked me
oh hey you don't happen to have your
gold card do you she has a card made out
of solid gold and diamonds
oh we want to see that you don't have it
with you so feel how heavy this is yeah
wait but that's
the other card makes that one feel like
paper the other card the other one has
gold and diamonds solid gold
who makes that card aurora lifestyles
i want a baymax the american express
black card
but you know you have to be invited by
american express to get one
like you can't ask like you can't get
one they have to offer you one right
so my mom got it is she had the second
highest credit card
and she was like asking people around
like how do i get the black
card and they said oh you had to spend
200 grand in one year
on this the platinum car so my mom said
okay
she went and she bought a lamborghini
murcielago for like 300 grand on the
credit card she just bought a
lamborghini and she's like
now can i have my black card and how can
you buy a lamp because i don't
i i've never seen at an auction at an
auction
at an auction she bought a 2005
i don't know she got a a marshall's
auction
online and they allow credit cards card
she never saw it she typed in her credit
card bought it online it was a gated
manual now the car's worth about a
million dollars
which which card it was this uh it was a
black gated
mercy logo let's talk about that watch
okay can we talk about that
no talk about the ring okay can we see
the talk about the seven figures you
want to sit down
seven figure diamonds do you want to sit
down yeah yeah yeah
podcast we have the one and only mom lad
joining us on the podcast
[Music]
and she's come here to show us her watch
wow jewelry
oh my god wow a fully iced out
is this is this factory or aftermarket
it's actually aftermarket okay
yeah yeah yeah it looks the same it
looks the same yeah when i see things i
rather get a deal
as well so you don't get a deal on that
ring though that's a seven figure ring
no this ring is 13 carats
it's well the one diamond is 13 carats
yeah
and so that's a solitaire at 13 carats
which is
you've probably never seen one this big
because i always go out and anytime i
see someone with a big ring i'm like
mine's bigger
not like christine right christine is
the only one christine from selling
sunsets how big is that
hers was worth i don't know how big it
was it's worth 1.2 million
yeah it's like nine hundred thousand
okay one i have earrings that are a
million but they're in a safety position
those are eight carrots each yeah he
actually did a video on my mother's
jewelry collection and then we were
right then we got robbed no they stole
wait wait wait they did a video they
didn't so in her closet
i did a video like touring her jewelry
collection because she actually like she
was on magazines for her custom jewelry
like
she has the yvonne collection that's
what it's known as she was famous for
her
jewelry back in the day so i made a
video about it in her closet
we leave town one weekend we come back
she takes a
shower she goes into her closet and i
just hear her scream i've been
robbed yeah and all of her purses are
missing there's only one purse left
and it's facing towards us they angled
it and it says rich [ __ ]
no so they like left a message and they
stole all of her purses
no she had she's collected clothing
she's owned consignment stores
so she had six figures worth of purses
that they stole
wow and so that must have been an
inside do you have do you suspect who
that was we lived in a private gated
guarded community and so it had to be an
inside job
yeah so we don't know we um could be
anyone
yeah and we were moving in the process
of moving
because we had rented our house to megan
machine gun kelly
and wow um
i was renting them the house and we were
uh scheduled to move like you know
two weeks so then we hired um protection
to sit at the house arm protection just
so we would feel safe
you know a funny thing i still haven't
told my mom about megan fox machine gun
kelly
remember how you were getting all those
amazon purchases for like
five dollars for movies and you're like
who's watching all these movies
i never signed out of that amazon
account on the tv at their house so it
was their kids
watching movies wow it was
megan fox's kids like who is watching
movies we were all out to dinner
but you detected the five dollar charge
of course i did yeah it's good
i detect every charge yeah i look at
everything
difference between the mom and the dad a
million dollar palm tree i forgot about
it
who's watching this yes yes and it was
actually
uh millions of dollars in palm trees
because he had to pull millions i think
20 olive trees out oh geez in order to
put the ball i feel bad for the olive
tree like i feel so bad
any plant that's like alive
yeah and so then it was the craning the
digging
the architectural plans everything which
was the amount
wow yeah jason's olive trees were like
five to eight but they were like mature
olive trees but yeah the the big trees
yeah 20.
these were pretty big yeah wow you had
20 of them oh can i
can we see the watch do you want to see
it yeah yeah yeah
it's just a rolex date no it's not i bet
i'm she wouldn't though
i don't it's not that yeah it's a
datejust no i
you know what that could be the big
datejust
oh my gosh this is crazy
wow i know it makes my watch like
where's your watch this is it's the
submariner
is that stainless steel yeah those are
worth like 40 grand now
my jeweler said if i could go in a store
and get one new new
sure he said cause if you go into a
rolex store there's nothing in the
windows there's nothing anywhere
so stainless steel one my jeweler told
me if i could get him one
he would my jeweler told me if i could
get him one new
he would give me the thirteen thousand i
paid for it and an extra
twenty thousand no there's no way
there's no way i don't know if you could
find them it's impossible
go to any rolex store and go in and try
to buy a men's yeah but you're not going
to
a dealer to buy that watch they said the
jewelers
you can only find them like aftermarket
so right you're welcome to see a few
so if you can get a new one they're
worth so much now how about that you
know what jack you should sell it for 20
right now i'm not gonna
you wouldn't sell it for 20. why dude
this is my oh my god
come on sell everything yeah jack cash
seriously
no because if donald wants to pay 24.
i'm telling you
20 grand you would be idiot not to sell
that watch for 20.
i would have to facetime my jewelry you
need to sell it you're welcome to
facetime your jewelry i i see you dude
come on this is my first watch
dude i'm telling you guys jack it was
because of me that you got that watch
and it's because of me you should sell
it for 20. it means a lot i don't care
how much it means 20 000 means more i'm
telling you
if you could if you could get 20 for
that watch right now take it
a hundred percent don't get them stupid
attached you'd be
stupid for that i was planning on giving
this to my son
i already like had plans
i don't have a girlfriend yet either but
that's in the works okay i was planning
on giving this to my son
and maybe if i sell it for 20 i wouldn't
be able to yeah
this is oh foot down sorry foot down
there you go gotta have my foot
down there's this all right well anyway
federico
talks watches uh really gave us a good
hook up on that watch
highly recommend him for if you want to
get a watch and i see you're not wearing
a watch right
i am not wearing federico if you're
watching this actually you you should we
could hook you up with federico
i could you get a watch where is he
florida
or we could try to go find the watch
after this podcast yeah so we had an
idea
uh we we could do this is uh going
shopping with the richest kid in america
for the vlog if you
want to do it if there's a place you
want to go shopping
is getting that pawn shop out here that
has all these gorillas
yeah yeah yeah wait wait you're talking
about rick harrison
no okay no it's all overpriced like have
you ever seen those those videos like
how much does your fit cost like have
you seen those oh yeah
i love these videos yeah yeah yeah can
we do that
[Music]
50 000 yeah sure four hundred dollars
yeah yeah perfect it's definitely gonna
be a lot i could go okay so this was
free
right that's good this was free found in
my mom's closet
um the pants probably like 40 bucks
those shoes look nice though i painted
those i made them myself
what how are you painting they were all
white and
wow yeah i painted them myself because
we had a pink prom for influencers
so i made pink jordans you did a good
job you were waiting
yeah get some b-roll how did you paint
that though there's a sharpie or what
uh no i did angelus leather paint i've
made like
probably like 10 pairs of custom shoes
wow it's one of my hobbies i just like
i like shoes so i design custom ones i
really like that i thought those
were just they were all white when i
yeah i was about to say i've never seen
them like that
and uh wow how much were the how much
were the shoes 110.
so my favorite less than 200 dollars
that's not bad
mom laughs let's
those are louis vuitton wow
if you don't know you don't know that's
why i like them because it doesn't say
it anywhere
i would have had no idea i know you know
and
but no one's right like looking it's not
like it doesn't have the classic louis
colors and stuff yeah
i think they're like 1700 no
wow are they comfortable because it
looks like they have a big arch
they look so uncomfortable they are
because i have a flat foot so it helps
actually
so it's like therapeutic that's why i
bought them there's therapeutic
[Music]
and then i have the fanny uh fendi fanny
pack
i think this was a good it was 1200
which isn't bad for like
you know handbag yeah type of thing
and then um the dress is i don't know
not that expensive probably a hundred
dollars
okay and then this is the ring which is
like a 900 000 ring and then the watch
is like
probably like what did i pay 50
i don't even remember it was like three
years ago okay
you also have a necklace in here these
were 700. the louis vuitton necklace
is this was against 700 or 700
thousand no 700 okay
you don't know anything i have no idea
yeah like costumes so this would be
costume 700 for costume
wow so this could almost be a million
dollar outfit
with the jewelry with the with the
jewelry with the jewelry clothes yeah
with tacks
you're next you got to get a watch i do
federico
i'm the only one here without a wall i
bought him a watch
i had a rolex and then it broke because
i bought him it was like a
diamond i said okay you're like 13. so
let's just get i was like 12.
like a 5 000 first rolex
stuff is that weird yeah beginner level
understand what's weird anymore i'm like
the entry level it's normal right
and so then it broke because it was
cheap how did it break
that's not cheap at all it was a rolex
and i exchanged it for a diamond dennis
bracelet for herself oh
so she took my watch and because it
broke she replaced it and got herself
a rolex break though that's what i'm
confused because this watch is
don't break unless unless like a unless
it was aftermarket and diamond it was
also a 12 year old it was only
a 12 year old yeah i think it was like
quit taking time
like you know how it's off motion or
whatever but it could just needed to be
winded it could have
been fixed it could have been no those
are all automatic watches
uh my guess is it probably just needed a
service and it had never been serviced
but i did take it to the jeweler and he
did do the exchange he said okay
but i just said give me something for
myself oh then that was it he probably
was just like at this point like it
doesn't matter
but yeah uh yeah when i got this it it
uh it hadn't been serviced ever so i
just got it for a service and it worked
perfectly
but yeah with rolex's i think like every
five ten years supposed to take it in
just
they lube up the uh the mechanics in the
watch and that's it they put it back
together
that was probably i don't think you did
anything to a lot of those watches are
indestructible you can't break them
tell us about your watch collection i
have
and i'm not like you knew exactly the
like in the model so i'm more like
i like that that's pretty so i like the
frank mueller because they do like the
funny numbers they do cool designs and
they're really cool so i have a couple
of those
and then i have like the roadster
cartier and so i have a couple different
ones in the gold and then the
silver and then i have um
hublot i bought that one in switzerland
on our trip which is more like sporty
and you were mad because they didn't
give you champagne right
yeah they wouldn't give her these
stories she's
while i show up they didn't give her any
because we were like walking around the
town dressed like
just normal people and then she got all
mad she bought the watch with her black
card and she's like next time bring me
champagne
i look nice right now but a lot of times
i'm like in sweats no makeup
and i'll walk in somewhere and they
don't want to help me whether it's a car
dealership or a jewelry store
and i'm like come on like i'm serious
i'm going to buy something yeah they're
like oh
let's see like they're very hesitant to
help me sometimes
based on i think a lot of people go
through that on appearance or whatever
yeah and so um sometimes i get agitated
yeah do you find it's the younger sales
people who are more dismissive or the
older sales people who have seen it all
i'm not sure i think it's a mixture of
both but
knowing i had a store like very high-end
consignment store
you never judge a book by its cover yeah
if you saw his father
i mean that in a good way but he's like
sleeve tattooed
mohawk really yeah i did not picture you
do you have a picture of me i did not
figure that at all
i imagine like a clean cut
polo shirt no there he is
the one and only dad lad that's the real
experience
i want to see dad lad i would not have
guessed it's just not what i expected
like what do you expect and i'll show
you the picture
now i guess i don't know what to expect
i guess the sleeves probably like really
red skin
red skin like like reddish tan leathery
skin
yeah he's not wrong
i say that i just oh my god he's
a legend what the heck
that's him posing for a thumbnail look
at his one of my videos do you have any
other pictures oh my gosh it's just yeah
that's his outfit and then like look at
his diamond chain like that's him
you know wear like super nice shoes a
diamond chain and then like a walmart
shirt that he's had for 20 years i would
love to have him on
yeah wow do wait so he always had like
the tattoos and the
the that sort of rocker he has a story
behind all of them
yeah and yeah he
he just keeps adding them on and on he
stopped a couple years ago but
just adds him along he has tattoos on
his head no way
all over he looks pretty good for 60
yeah yeah
i guess he used to be very very big
uh he would like bench in the 300s
and he was like big into working out
like he was huge
like he was that guy walking by you're
like whoa that's just
he seems like six foot he was he was six
four he shrunk now to six two he's six
two now
shrunk to 16 i mean he's 65. yeah he's a
good time
he would be really good on a podcast
because yeah he's very articulate
deep voice very funny you know he likes
to kill rattlesnakes and skin them and
make bandanas i mean
oh he's way out of the way bananas out
of the snake yes
yeah oh my god and then he has two dogs
um
his dog is actually way more than me is
one dog
the bigger one still a puppies the puppy
is 175
pound tibetan mastiff wow yeah
and then he also has another tibetan
mastiff he has two
african savannah cats he paid twenty
thousand dollars for one cat
that is so cool they're like this long
the kittens still they they can jump
they jump like
once i saw one jump over my dad six foot
tall man
when we got married he had a wolf
and a snake yeah he had a wolf then by a
snake
like a six foot snake wow yeah that
would swim with it how was he able to
balance that
with like him with him i was able to
balance that with like running this
business at the same time
i'm always curious about that because
it's like fran
you hire good people really you have
some i used to oversee a lot of it and
then he's had a secretary the same
lady for like secretaries managers 25
years who's
you know it's not that complicated when
you're dealing with rents collecting
rents and
yes you have accountants and things like
that that oversee it so it's not really
a hands-on type of business it can be if
you choose to
yeah but it's kind of like i own
different
things as well and i just collect the
rent and have other people do all the
other stuff that's smart
tell us about like what what he was like
for you growing up as a as a father was
was he just as crazy of a of a figure
and like doing
stuff like that with you yeah
he was um so like he
he what i don't i didn't
they got divorced they like split up
when i was like eight years old so i
would see him on the weekends
so it wasn't like i grew up like with
him every day
but i always like i know he does a lot
of crazy things
and like once he picked us up from the
airport in a new car because my mom
wouldn't let him buy like cars so we
went to new york we come back and he
like bought a new car
he bought a gtr because he he liked it
but my mom's like oh no not a nissan
but she likes it because it's faster
than her lambo right
i could negotiate a better deal that's
all i walked in on car dealerships
before and he would be sitting behind
the desk ready to sign
yeah and i would say what are you
selling him and he would be like
i'm selling him a new used to like the
sailing cobra mustangs or whatever
and i'm like and what's your price and
i'd get my phone out and he's like we're
selling it for this and what year and
then i get on the phone i'm like
i call the dealership the competitor i'm
like can you beat this price and i'm
like let's go we got another one because
he's uh emotional buyer
yeah so so are you have that's what i
told jason today i'm like we gotta go
shopping with mom lad because she won't
leave a store without buying stuff oh we
gotta we gotta go we gotta go
[Laughter]
sounds good for me i'll buy if you bite
there is nothing that i want there's
nothing this until you see it until you
see it in person
i would i'll go i'll look but i can't
promise i'd buy because there's not
there's nothing that i would need
you got to get like a gucci belt or
something
i don't even i'm not even wearing a belt
right now that's your problem dude
see exactly i wear my vesties
[Music]
everywhere yeah they're free shoes i
like those i
here's the thing i i wouldn't mind a
pair of gucci shoes but i would be so
paranoid about getting them like scuffed
or dirty
would never wear them do you go to nice
dinners
uh super sushi 20 all you can do 21 all
you can eat sushi
[Music]
why am i blanking on the name the
steakhouse herbs and rye
herbs and rye they got a happy hour
until i think it's 7 p.m right now
uh half-price steaks and they have some
of the best steaks i've ever had
and i think it comes out like half price
like 30 bucks for a filet
so you don't go to like stk or
for the experience no no herbs and why
it's just
gonna be giving her a chance yeah i know
i already know i know the question
my point was gonna be the dinner is like
three four hundred dollars that's a pair
of shoes or you know two dinners but if
you don't even
if you don't even go to dinner it
doesn't no no it doesn't like it doesn't
even quite because i did like weight
loss things like we got a really nice
dinner so when my mom's like we cook at
home she's like you just saved 200 bucks
a meal at home no the nicest meal
was so uh well the first time we went
out to like a really expensive
restaurant
uh it was that it was free justin uh
works at a place called yellowtail
and it was one of the best meals in my
entire life but that probably worked out
to be about
200 and something a person but that was
like
the first time i've ever experienced
something like that you like the first
time
i love you like i didn't like nobu i
hate you
you don't like nobu i love nobu yeah
i went to the west hollywood nobu which
i hear is like the worst one and the
malibu one is the best yeah
so right now we got an iced coffee hour
exclusive
that's just on the clips channel where
we're gonna be going over all of your
questions to ask the richest kid in
america
so if you want to see that the link is
down below in the description it's only
going to be there
so go and click the link right now is
there something that for you is so
expensive that you would not spend money
on it that you feel like that's not
worth it
no but there's things that are so
expensive that'll get a good deal on it
like my mclaren i got for 33
000 under sticker price brand new so
that i could sell it today for the same
price i paid yeah so always make sure
i'll buy really nice things but i will
not buy it at retail i'll make sure to
get a good deal
yeah how were you able to get it that
much off msrp
um her friend is the manager of the
dealership
it was the end of the year and they had
one really good deal and
she's like yvonne this is it
and he was trying to make me buy the one
with the bigger engine i bought the 570.
he wanted me to buy the seven whatever
and i'm oh it's 720 720 yeah
and i said it's about the deal her 570
was a convertible no the other one was a
better deal because
it's used yeah but it's still just a
whole different type of
it is yeah like the 720 is like a
different league
like number 570
yeah okay all right so we already argued
about this before
i want to know about cars like how many
cars do you have what are the cars do
you have a car
you're wait 15 or 16. sorry i forgot um
i have a car
i'm not even no my mom will get mad if i
say it because she doesn't know i have
this car
you have a car i'd get it for you yeah
dad got me a car
but i'm not even going to say it because
my mom will get mad
we know we're not he's too late if i say
what type of car my mom will get mad
why listen we're here in a safe spot i'm
going to make sure she doesn't get okay
okay wait it's okay
because it's a very fast car it's
and he has it now it'll destroy a
lamborghini wait where is it
it's it's his car that he stopped
driving
the nissan the gtr yeah oh you're not
allowed to drive that no way i told you
it's just not angry though i've kept
that a secret for like two years
that's there's no way it's a thousand
horsepower you don't get that is it
supercharged
or what is it uh he's gotta be super he
took out the engine and put a new
like it took apart the engine and put
every every part is
upgraded 200 grand into the engine
what car would you like to see your sun
drive
like a bullet proof like probably like
do you know what i think we have a volvo
out front i will tell you i think
maybe i did i should have raised him
more prudently and more
not so glamorous both of my children
because i think
you miss out on the drive to have the
nice thing in life
and so if i could change i try i'm
trying to change it now but it's too
late
so i'm always like you're spoiled you
shouldn't have that but it's too late
because it was raised that way yeah and
so if i could go back
i probably would not have been buying
him the gucci at 11 years old
or at like eight do you think it's too
late
yeah it is of course you would want to
say that though right like what
he would he would have an interest in
saying it's too late though right
no i i i think that uh
no i think yeah by 16 you've kind of got
those experiences already
and then when you lose the experience
because i say when you're 18 you're on
your own
like you're living in my house now
you're driving around in the mclaren
yeah but once you hit 18 that's over but
my daughter
i can drive who's 26 she's like i'm like
go get married go meet get out of my
house yeah because
jack jack's single look at this
here we go slow your roll check you can
move in too
the mistake is had she not go to these
boarding schools
and traveled the world and she went to
school in london
so now when she comes back i'm like okay
go get your little
apartment in la and move out and go get
a job she's like what
like are you going to get me the
apartment it's never ending
she has a seven figure education right
yes
and so um where did she go what did she
study she went to boarding school
which is extremely expensive in the
travel back and forth on planes and
more expensive than college like per
year yeah boarding school
67. we had we had a family friend
growing up that was
not not your experience necessarily but
uh the
the father was really well accomplished
and i think the kids
when they hit 18 neither one of them had
a desire to do anything because they
knew that they were never going to be
able to top what their dad did
uh because it was it was so grand and uh
i feel like
so yeah well i mean which i don't think
they had that same drive but i think a
lot of it was
what's the point whatever i do on my own
is going to be so inconsequential i mean
if
i make a hundred thousand a year this
you know compared to what
you know he may it's it's not even worth
it um
so both of them kind of fizzled uh i
think their son still lives in
he's in his 30s but never left just
because it's like what's the
point and and their house is so nice
that it's like
that yeah what you want for me i agree i
agree i
want them to go off on their own and
leave the nest and i think like
you need to go through the hardship to
build character
my hardest points built me now so like
if anything happens
i'm thick-skinned my kids have never
gone through anything hard
so how are they when they go out there
and get rejected i have gone through
a dece like a little have you have less
no i did 55 videos in 25 days because my
girlfriend at the time
she also did vlogmas and we were doing
couples videos
so i did 25 videos and i was six videos
ahead i lost five videos to a corrupted
sd card
so i had to re-shoot five videos for the
last uh
six days of vlogmas and then my the
girlfriend at the time she also did
vlogmas 55 videos in 25 days
but yeah but that's a drive so you you
have a desire to go do something i think
so i think you're all over eight minutes
yeah yeah i don't know i'm not i
wouldn't be worried about you
but i think i think the bar was set high
but i wouldn't i i could already tell
you have the drive
so do you want to meet my daughter
jack
he's turning all red little nuts
the richest step kid in america
[Music]
yes come on jack
jack's a great guy really nice stop
trying to sell me man
so so we're done with the eclipse
segment right like the eclipse okay just
checking
she's really smart
[Laughter]
well that's that's good very nice she's
funny
yeah she's a little bit of a brat though
she's snarling a lot a lot
how would you feel if jack was dating
your sister dude
that'd be we all wish she had a
boyfriend
we all i'm like go get a boyfriend get
out of that emma move out
i have a more active dating life than
her
26 yes than her nice man
she's like why would i leave this and
then she sits out on the balcony i'm
like get out of my house
but there must be a part of you that
enjoys having her around and like
enjoying the company right
we're done yeah but here's the thing
when she leaves you're going to be
bummed out that she left
she left twice and i made her move back
home exactly and that's
see there we go that's that's yeah the
exact case i go and i visit my parents
and then like i'm there and they're like
all right
i gotta go and then i leave and then
like when are you coming back when you
come in yeah and that's just how it is
that's how parents are
yeah exactly she actually is the one who
did all the editing for him
no way it was just them two in the
beginning all the filming all the
editing
everything she was the film producing
directing because i was
not a youtuber i was not i learned and
taught myself
and she helped like to become natural on
camera
and like how to talk but in the
beginning i was very very very bad
she would be like serious say this
sentence and then i'd say and then
now say this sentence and like my
first youtube videos weren't even me it
was like my sister threw me
yeah it takes practice it takes a lot of
practice to do it
thank you guys so much for coming on
this is awesome coming all the way to
las vegas for this i really appreciate
it and
as a thank you for coming on i will give
you some bankroll coffee
that's awesome now for sale at
bankrollcoffee.com
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i'll link to all of
your information down below in the
description
where you could also get a free stock
that's now worth all the way up to
seventy dollars
seventy dollars you may as well just do
that because it's pretty much like free
money
and i'm posting all of my own stock
trades on there so if you wanna be a
part of it the link is down below in the
description
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
intro that yeah